[Music]
uh yeah the game between you and Wesley
saw finished in the draw tell us a
little bit about it what happened
well Wesley chose one of the most uh
solid lines against the cattle on the
end because it's also the lion I playing
the game I played against him
like knows you know these lines
more or less more or less a draw so I I
try to repeat the language
here in Rapid yeah but this probably was
a bad idea because it was really
prepared and he came up with all the
best moves and yeah
it's one of the computers one of the
drawers which one of the shows sometimes
it goes like this yeah exactly did you
notice I mean I'm sure you noticed that
Magnus didn't show up for the game did
you see his tweet before the round or
you will learn the news after no somehow
I'm trying not to spend
a lot of time on socials uh during the
tournament with the game now you say
there is there is a treat okay I'll come
and check it but yeah probably
we're already set the reason
absolutely what do you think about his
game Wisconsin yesterday do you think it
was affected by the results
oh yeah in some way for sure but uh yeah
it was more than impressive absolutely
thank you so much Xian and all the best
in the next rounds
[Music]